هذا هو قد اعلن الجيش اللبناني طاقه عدد
من الصواريخ من محيط بلدات القليله
والمعليه وزدقين واكد تسير دوريات
بالتعاون مع قوات حفظ السلام اليونيفي
وكشف في بيان له عن العثور على منصات
الصواريخ وصواريخ معده للاطلاق في بلدتي
سبقين والقليله جنوبيه لبنان مؤكدا بانه
يجري العمل على تفكيكها في هذه الاثناء
حمل الجيش الاسرائيلي الحكومه اللبنانيه
ماسونيه اطلاق صواريخ من داخل اراضيها نحو
اسرائيل وعصف العمليه بالحدث الخطير وتهم
الجيش الاسرائيلي حركه حماس في لبنان
بالوقوف وراء الطاقه القذائف الصاروخيه
مشيرا الى انه يفحص احتمال تورط ايران في
العمليه من جهه نقل موقع ولا الاسرائيليه
ان الخارجيه الاسرائيليه خاطبت السفرائها
في الدول الاجنبيه بشان نيتها الرد على
الهجوم وطلبت منهما الاستعداد
لتفسير الرد الاسرائيلي
هذا وقبل قليل قال بيان لوزاره الدفاع
الاسرائيليا وزير الدفاع امر الجيش
الاسرائيلي باعداد جميع الخيارات الممكنه
للرد على الهجوم الصاروخي من لبنان
لتقديمها الى مجلس الوزراء الامني وقالت
هيئه البث الاسرائيليه
قالت ان وزير الدفاع اقترح تعزيز خيارات
الرد على اطلاق النار من لبنان لعرضها على
مجلس الوزراء
وكان مراسل للجزيره افادى
اجتماعا لهيئه اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي
لدراسه الرد على الهجوم الصاروخيه من
لبنان